[Intro]
SALLY: Schatz, ich bin so weit. Kommst du?
Hauptsache mein Papa gießt im Hintergrund den Garten,
obwohl wir eine Bewässerungsanlagen haben. Egal!
Warte!
Hallo, Baba! (Gutes Gelingen!)
Der Papa. Ach Gott!
Komm, wir klatschen zusammen!
MURAT: So, wann fangen wir an? Jetzt?
SALLY: Na jetzt!
Ich habe schon auf Record.
MURAT: Ich drücke jetzt, okay?
SALLY: Ja, warte ganz kurz für ein Video Einstieg.
Also herzlich willkommen zu Sallys Welt.
Heute ist unser 50. Podcast
und deswegen haben wir in unserer Community Fragen gesammelt
und mein Team hat mir 50 Fragen einfach rausgesucht,
die wir jetzt gemeinsam beantworten werden.
MURAT: Du und ich? [Sally bejaht]
SALLY: Dennis und die anderen haben gesagt, es sind 50 Fragen
und wir müssen alle beantworten, ganz ehrlich …
MURAT: Dann müssen wir schnell machen.
SALLY: und wir müssen jede beantworten, auch wenn es unangenehm ist.
MURAT: Dann ist es besser, wenn ich sie nicht beantworte, weil …
SALLY: Auch wenn es unangenehm ist wird!
MURAT: Auch wenn es unangenehm ist? [Sally bejaht]
SALLY: Und wenn du eine Frage nicht beantwortet,
dann gilt Wahrheit oder Pflicht - dann musst du etwas tun.
MURAT: Okay.
SALLY: [Lacht] Okay, komm wir starten!
MURAT: Fangen wir an..
SALLY: Oh, ich habe was vergessen: [lacht] meine Kopfhörer!
MURAT: Herzlich willkommen zu unserem
sage und schreibe
50. Podcast der Ehetherapie!
Herzlich willkommen!
Vor mir sitzt die liebe Sally
SALLY: und der wundervolle Murat.
MURAT: Das ist der 50. Podcast, also 50 Wochen lang.
50 Wochen sind fast ein Jahr, gell? [Sally bejaht]
Das Jahr hat - wie viele? - 56 Wochen?
SALLY: [Flüstert] 52.
MURAT: 52? Oh, dann sind wir schon drüber. Das ging aber schnell.
Boah krass!
SALLY: Hä? Wir haben 50!
MURAT: Ja?
SALLY: Also in 2 Wochen wäre Einjähriges.
MURAT: Ach so! Okay. Alles klar.
SALLY: [Lacht] Mathe war nicht so seine Stärke.
MURAT: Ihr müsst einfach richtig heiraten. Das ist wichtig.
SALLY: Wir haben uns gedacht,
zum 50. Podcast werden wir 50 Fragen von euch beantworten.
Ich habe neulich in der Story die Fragen gesammelt.
Dennis und mein Team haben die Fragen uns gescreenshottet.
Deswegen habe ich auch das Handy vor mir liegen.
Und wir beantworten jede Frage,
egal, ob sie unangenehm ist oder nicht, okay?
MURAT: Ich bin mal gespannt.
SALLY: Ja, aber der Podcast sollte jetzt auch keine 50 Stunden dauern.
Deswegen …
[Andreas]: Halt stopp!
halten wir jetzt direkt ran und werden die Fragen beantworten.
Übrigens, alle, die gerade nur zuhören und nicht so schauen …
[Andreas]: Halt stopp!
Wir haben …
Nimm die Finger weg von den Knöpfen!
Wir nehmen den Podcast übrigens auch als Video-Podcast auf.
Also falls ihr einmal schauen wollt,
wie es bei uns hier im Podcast-Büro aussieht,
dann könnt ihr gerne das Video auf YouTube schauen.
MURAT: Oder wenn ihr auf YouTube seid und ihr wollt dem Podcast anhören,
dann geht ihr auf Spotify, Deezer, Audio Now oder wie auch immer.
SALLY: Ganz genau.
MURAT: Und der ist kostenlos.
SALLY: Okay, also ich fange jetzt einfach
MURAT: Okay, aber ich schwöre es dir:
Wenn es irgendetwas Perverses ist, bin ich raus.
SALLY: Ja okay,
Okay, was war die schwerste Zeit, durch die ihr gegangen seid?
Ich glaube, eine schwere Zeit war die Bauphase.
Das kann wahrscheinlich jedes Ehepärchen verstehen.
MURAT: Da gab es eine schlimmere Zeit ganz am Anfang.
SALLY: Wir hatten schon viele Höhen und Tiefen, muss ich sagen,
aber ich glaube, es kommt immer drauf an,
wie man mit solchen Situation umgeht.
Und ich glaube, wir zwei sind echt ein gutes Team.
Toi, toi, toi.
MURAT: Und wie sagt man?
Am wichtigsten ist es, dass man gesund ist.
Das ist das Allerwichtigste. Alles andere kommt danach.
SALLY: Ich bin einfach wirklich sehr froh, dass wir beide gesund sind,
dass unsere Kinder, unsere Familien, die Eltern alle gesund sind.
Das ist für mich erst einmal das Wichtigste.
Alles andere, muss ich sagen, …
Das sind Dinge, wo ich mir denke, so schlimm ist es nicht.
Egal, ob du mal finanziell am Boden bist,
das waren wir auch schon tatsächlich,
also wirklich auch schon ganz schlimm.
Wir sind da durchgegangen, weil ich mir denke,
das ist kein Weltuntergang und man kann eben alles schaffen.
Aber wichtig ist einfach, dass man gesund ist.
Und deswegen:
Jeder, der gesund ist,
sollte seine Gesundheit auch wertschätzen. [Murat stimmt zu]
Das ist keine Selbstverständlichkeit.
Es gibt so viele Kinder, so viele Eltern, Familien, Alleinstehende,
die einfach krank sind und denen geht es schlechter als euch.
Und deswegen:
Egal, wie schlimm die Situation auch erscheint,
egal, wie sehr ihr am Tiefpunkt seid,
es gibt immer einen Weg raus!
MURAT: Auf Türkisch gibt es einen Spruch, den ich mal kurz sage:
Cana gelsin, mala gelmesin. (Lieber Personen- statt Sachschaden).
SALLY: Mala gelsin, cana gelmesin. (Lieber Sach- statt Personenschaden).
[Beide lachen] Du bist so blöd. Er hat gedacht, ich merke es nicht!
Was sind eure Lieblingsfarben?
MURAT: Ach Schatz! Wie kann man sowas fragen?
SALLY: Ach komm, ich habe die Fragen nicht rausgesucht.
MURAT: Das haben wir damals ins Poesiealbum geschrieben, mit Hobbys …
Ich ziehe immer schwarz an.
Also seitdem ich zugenommen habe, ziehe ich nur schwarz an.
SALLY: Meine Lieblingsfarbe ist tatsächlich immer noch Magenta,
aber auch Salbeigrün zurzeit. Ich liebe Salbeigrün.
Einfach schön!
Nimm die Finger weg von den Knöpfen!
[Polizistenstimme] Bitte helfen Sie mir!
Ich bin in Gefahr. Bitte helfen Sie mir!
MURAT: Okay, ich wollte nur wissen, was das überhaupt ist.
Hör auf jetzt!
Okay, weiter geht's.
SALLY: Was sind eure Lieblingsbücher?
MURAT: Und zwar habe ich das schon mal gesagt.
Übrigens schreibt mich gestern komischerweise einer an und sagt:
Danke für den Buchtipp.
Das war das genialste Buch, das ich jemals gelesen habe:
Und zwar von Carlos Ruiz Zafón „Im Schatten des Windes"
- ist ein Roman.
Das ist der einzige Roman, den ich wirklich mal gelesen habe,
aber der war so gigantisch.
SALLY: Ich kann mir das gar nicht vorstellen,
dass du mal einen Roman gelesen hast,
dass du die Konzentration dafür hast.
[Kinder-Lachton]
Hör jetzt auf mit den Knöpfen!
Es nervt!
Ich sag's, ich binde dir die Hände sonst weg.
Okay, alles klar!
MURAT: Also „Im Schatten des Windes" von Carlos Ruiz Zafón.
SALLY: Ich muss sagen, ich habe kein Lieblingsbuch,
weil ich ein Buch einmal lese und das war's.
Und wenn ich es gut fand, dann empfehle ich es auch gern.
MURAT: Wer liest denn Bücher zweimal.
SALLY: Ja, deswegen!
Deswegen verstehe auch ich die Frage nach dem Lieblingsbuch nicht.
MURAT: Das Buch, das ich gerade gelesen habe.
SALLY: Was du vielleicht ganz toll fandest.
Ich fand zum Beispiel „Ein ganzes halbes Jahr" ganz toll.
Da habe ich Rotz und Wasser geheult.
Ich habe aber auch echt gern andere Bücher gelesen.
„The Mister", dann die 3 Bücher von „Fifty Shades of Grey",
dann lese ich Thriller gern.
MURAT: Weiter geht's.
SALLY: Wünschst du dir manchmal mehr Zeit für dich selbst?
MURAT: Natürlich! Ich glaube, das wünscht sich jeder Mensch.
SALLY: Ich glaube, das wünscht sich echt jeder.
Vor allem als Eltern, muss man sagen, opfert man …
Was heißt Opfern? Man macht es ja gerne,
aber jetzt positiv ausgedrückt opfert man viel Zeit für die Kinder,
natürlich auch für die Ehe, für die Familie, für Freunde.
Und ich denke, man selbst kommt oft zu kurz.
Das muss ich z.B. auch lernen,
dass ich mir einfach bisschen mehr Zeit nehme.
Ich weiß noch, dass ich bis vor kurzem immer gesagt habe:
Ich bin gar nicht so gern allein.
Ich bin schon immer gern in Gesellschaft.
Ich liebe es, Freunde da zu haben, Familie, Kinder, Ehemann.
Aber tatsächlich genieße ich es auch mal zurzeit,
wenn ich mal echt so eine Stunde einfach allein bin
und nichts spreche, nichts tue.
Also was heißt, nichts tun.
Ich mache dann vielleicht Sport
oder - keine Ahnung -
kümmere mich halt einfach um mich.
MURAT: Ich würde gerne wieder mal mit Fussballspielen anfangen.
SALLY: Das kannst du machen.
MURAT: Ich würde wirklich gerne mit Fußballspielen anfangen.
Da hätte ich richtig Lust drauf.
SALLY: Fänd ich auch schön.
Und ich würde auch mal gerne mit Kumpels fortgehen.
MURAT: Ja, mach das.
Ich habe nur noch den Ali als Kumpel, nur noch den Ali.
SALLY: Und Güni?
MURAT: Güni habe ich auch. Das sind die einzigen.
SALLY: Şaban?
Badi, Dennis …
MURAT: Die nutzen mich nur aus. [Sally lacht]
Wollte ich nur sagen.
SALLY: Ja, ich muss mir auch wieder ein bisschen mehr Zeit für mich nehmen
und einfach mal wieder auf mich hören,
auf das, worauf ich jetzt gerade Lust habe.
Das, finde ich, ist schon wichtig, dass man das macht.
Aber jetzt haben wir auch gerade Schulferien in Baden-Württemberg.
Die meisten bei uns haben auch Urlaub,
also jetzt gerade Sarah und Josh,
mit denen ich natürlich täglich arbeite, haben gerade Urlaub.
MURAT: Mit deinen Eltern würde ich gern mehr Zeit verbringen. [Sally stimmt zu]
Ich würde so gern mit deinem Papa zusammen reisen. [Sally stimmt zu]
Ich würde gern mit ihm nach China oder auch nach Afrika reisen.
SALLY: Aber ich glaube, mein Papa würde das nicht wollen.
Nicht weil er die Länder nicht mag,
sondern er hätte, glaube ich, ein bisschen - nicht Angst -,
aber er mag so das Fremde ….
Ich glaube, da fürchtet er sich so ein bisschen davor.
Aber ich denke, dass es schon für die beiden recht cool wäre.
Die sind nicht so abenteuerlustig. Das ist das Wort, das mir fehlt.
Seid ihr glücklich, so wie es gerade ist? PS: Ihr seid mega toll!
Danke. Ihr seid auch alle mega toll.
Ich bin tatsächlich echt glücklich, so wie es gerade ist,
weil ihr euch das so vorstellen:
Klar, arbeiten wir viel
und es ist auch gerade echt viel, was wir haben,
mit Baustelle usw.,
aber es ist so, dass uns das alles viel zurückgibt.
Also mich macht es glücklich, wenn ich jeden Morgen aufstehe
und ich sehe die ganzen schönen Pflanzen, die Mitarbeiter
und wir haben all das einfach jeden Tag.
Ich bin jeden Tag glücklich.
MURAT: Ich finde, mir geht es ein bisschen zu schnell.
SALLY: Was? Und das sagst du?
MURAT: Ja, wirklich! Mir geht es ein bisschen zu schnell.
D.h., man kann oftmals die Momente nicht so genießen,
weil schon wieder das nächste Highlight kommt,
muss ich ganz ehrlich sagen. Ich würde gern …
SALLY: Ich habe auch neulich mit einem Freund drüber gesprochen …
MURAT: Ich würde so gerne mal unter der Woche einfach auf dem Balkon sitzen.
SALLY: Ja, aber das kann man doch machen.
Es liegt ja in unserer Hand. [Murat widerspricht]
Ja, doch, eigentlich schon.
Du kannst ja echt mal sagen:
So! Und heute lasse ich es jetzt mal liegen und mache morgen weiter.
MURAT: Das Problem ist halt, dass wir hier auch arbeiten und auch leben.
Das ist für mich ein Problem.
Also was heißt, es ist ein Problem? Es ist etwas Wundervolles.
Es ist ein Privileg, das zu machen. Das hat eine guten Seiten.
Aber die schlechte Seite ist:
Ich kann jetzt z.B. nicht auf dem Balkon sitzen,
während andere arbeiten. Es geht nicht. Das kann ich nicht.
SALLY: Deswegen! Aber ich glaube, das wird jetzt besser,
wenn dann alle Mitarbeiter und das ganze Team ins Nebengebäude ziehen.
Dann haben wir auch wieder ein bisschen mehr Privatsphäre
und es wird für uns echt gut, weil das stimmt auch:
Dass auch bei uns unter der Woche z.B.,
wenn ich dann drüben arbeite und drehe
und Murat im Respberry oder egal wo arbeitet,
dann ist es auch so, dass ich z.B. …
Mit Samira geht es. Sie es schon 10.
Dann kann sie schon Freunde einladen
und mit denen hier spielen und Zeit verbringen.
Bei Ela - sie will ich nicht alleine lassen.
Sie ist ja erst 5 und wenn da jetzt eine 5-jährige Freundin dazukommt …
Wir haben einen Teich, wir haben einen Garten.
Dann hätte ich Angst, dass da etwas passiert.
Sie kann ich dann nicht alleine lassen.
D.h., Ela hat immer nur Freunde am Wochenende da,
wenn wir auch frei haben.
MURAT: Aber wie gesagt, die Vorteile überwiegen
SALLY: Ja auf jeden Fall. Definitiv.
Also ich würde es nicht anders machen wollen.
Habt ihr jemals gedacht, dass ihr selbstständig sein werdet?
Ich tatsächlich nicht, denn ich war immer …
MURAT: Ich schon.
SALLY: Ja? Du warst ja auch vorher selbstständig, auch vor mir schon.
MURAT: Ich war eigentlich schon immer selbstständig.
SALLY: Und ich war immer so ein Sicherheitsmensch.
Ich wollte Beamtin werden und Lehrerin sein.
MURAT: Selbständig, also einfach morgens ganz normal irgendwo arbeiten,
wegen der Sicherheit und mittags dann Schwarzarbeit.
SALLY: [Räuspert] Ja.
In welches Land wollt ihr unbedingt mal verreisen?
Ich will unbedingt nach Japan.
MURAT: Ja. Ich glaube, Japan ist auch so mein Ding.
SALLY: Japan, das ist wow!
Nach Schottland will ich auch mal, Irland …
MURAT: Auf Kanada hätte ich auch mal Bock! [Sally stimmt zu]
SALLY: Ich würde ja echt auch mal gerne nach Australien,
aber ich habe da Angst vor den ganzen Tieren.
Josh war ja mal ein Jahr lang dort und dann hat er mir erzählt,
wie da die Riesenspinnen … und dann bin ich raus.
MURAT: Also Japan wäre wirklich der Wahnsinn!
SALLY: Finnland …
MURAT: Nein, ist mir zu kalt,
auch wenn es manche schreiben, dass die auch Sommer haben, ich weiß.
SALLY: … und Georgien soll auch toll sein. [Murat stimmt zu]
Sag mal, füßelst du gerade mit mir?
Wir nehmen gerade einen Video-Podcast auf.
Hör auf damit! [Lacht]
MURAT: Tut mir leid!
SALLY: Wie lange benutzt ihr jeden Tag euer Handy?
MURAT: Ich habe gestern wirklich geguckt. Jetzt mal ohne Spaß!
Aber ich mein, ich bin anders als …
Wir auch erst gestern …
SALLY: Wir haben gestern drüber geredet.
MURAT: Ich war gestern 3 Stunden am Handy
SALLY: Oh, das ist aber tatsächlich noch relativ gut für dich, finde ich.
MURAT: Willst du mich veräppeln? Wer hockt denn schon 3 Stunden am Handy?
SALLY: Ganz ehrlich, ich habe neulich bei meinen Freunden auch geguckt
und die sind alle länger am Handy als ich und das ist mein Hauptberuf.
Ich finde, dafür, dass es mein Hauptberuf ist,
bin ich echt recht wenig am Handy.
MURAT: Aber das hat seine Gründe,
weil ich natürlich viel mit den Zuschauern schreibe.
Also egal, ob auf der Leckereien-Gruppe bei Facebook
oder die Instagram-Fragen, die mir Zuschauer schicken,
oder einfach was poste
oder ich lese voll oft Nachrichten.
Also ich bin kein Mensch …
Ihr werdet mich niemals daddeln sehen.
Ich mache keine Spiele oder gucke mir irgendwelche Schmuddel-Seiten an.
Ich gucke wirklich nur Nachrichten und antworte Menschen.
SALLY: Ja, und bei mir ist so:
Ich habe im Tagesdurchschnitt der letzten Woche auch drei Stunden,
hatte das aber tatsächlich nur, das muss ich dazu sagen,
weil wir ein Kittchen gemacht haben.
Da hatte ich dann viele Reals aufgenommen und viele Videos und Fotos.
Aber ansonsten habe ich einen Tagesdurchschnitt von 1,5 Stunden
und das finde ich echt gut. [Murat stimmt zu]
Wobei ich sagen muss,
dass ich Kommentare meistens am Laptop beantworte,
weil ich da schneller bin.
Also ich glaube, im Schnitt bin ich 2,5 Stunden digital
und das, finde ich, geht.
Ich gucke dann auch nach Effizienz.
Also ich daddel dann auch nicht rum.
Klar gucke ich mir auch mal Reals und Storys an.
Aber ich bin schon so, dass ich dann die Zeit effizient nutze
und dann das Handy weglege.
MURAT: Mein Handy ist jetzt z.B. nicht da,
aber schlimm, wenn du überall Menschen siehst,
wo das Genick Richtung Boden geknickt ist. Das ist Wahnsinn! [Sally stimmt zu]
SALLY: Gut, dann fragt eine Zuschauerin:
Oft habe ich das Gefühl, dass ich im Leben nicht vorankomme.
Habt ihr Ratschläge?
MURAT: Ich glaube …
Du musst dann richtig heiraten. [Sally lacht]
Macht es auch! Das habe ich auch gemacht.
SALLY: Musst du gar nicht.
Ich glaube, dass viele Menschen sich Ziele setzen, die zu hoch sind.
Dann hat man das Gefühl, man kommt nicht weiter.
Ich glaube, wenn man sich kleinere, realistischere Ziele setzt,
dann hat man zum einen die Motivation, das auch zu schaffen.
Ich sage jetzt auch nicht, dass ihr euch nie hohe Ziele setzen könnt.
Ich meine, wir haben uns auch immer hohe Ziele gesetzt, oder Träume …
Oder es ist aus Zufall passiert. Das kann auch sein. [Sally stimmt zu]
Aber ich glaub, dass man irgendwie lernen muss,
mal kleinere Steps zu machen, zufrieden zu sein
und dann auch zu sagen:
Manchmal gibt Situationen, die man nicht ändern kann
und dann ist es halt so. Dann muss man sich damit abfinden.
MURAT: Man muss auch überlegen:
Man startet ja irgendwo, hat ein Ziel.
Und das Ziel ist, sagen wir mal, so 3 Meter entfernt,
so wie hier z.B.
Es ist ja so, dass man ein Ziel hat und auf das Ziel zugeht
und man hat das Ziel immer vor Augen.
Aber wie heißt der Spruch?
Der ist jetzt ein bisschen abgedroschen.
Der Weg ist das Ziel.
D.h., unterwegs passiert so viel Cooles.
Aber manche Menschen sind so fokussiert auf ihr Ziel,
dass sie das unterwegs gar nicht mehr wahrnehmen,
was dabei alles passiert. [Sally stimmt zu]
SALLY: Und das ist ja auch Wertschätzung. [Murat stimmt zu]
MURAT: Da gibt es einen ganz, ganz berühmten Erfinder, der gesagt hat:
Er hat auf dem Weg zum Ziel mehr erfunden als am Ziel.
Also er hat sich dann zur Aufgabe gemacht,
ich werde jetzt, keine Ahnung …
SALLY: Einen Teller mit Goldrand erfinden.
MURAT: … einen Teller mit Goldrand erfinden.
Dann war auf dem Weg, den Teller mit Goldrand zu erfinden
und hat unterwegs so viel neue Sachen erfunden.
Deswegen muss man sich natürlich immer Ziele setzen,
aber die Augen offen halten und immer auf den Boden schauen.
Die coolsten Sachen liegen meistens auf dem Boden. [Sally stimmt zu].
SALLY: Vielleicht kannst du dir auch abends immer 3 Stichpunkte aufschreiben,
was du den Tag über erreicht hast,
was du vielleicht Neues gelernt hast, was positiv war.
Ich glaube, wenn man sich das aufschreibt und es einmal visuell hat
und sich dann immer wieder rückblickend durchlesen kann,
dann sieht man auch, dass man Ziele erreicht.
MURAT: Und noch einmal:
Wir haben auch stetig Rückschläge.
Wir sind auch demoralisiert.
Wir sind auch mal kaputt.
Wir haben auch mal keinen Bock.
Das ist etwas völlig, völlig Normales.
Also das ist gar nicht …
Also es ist wirklich etwas völlig Normales und …
[Tusch]
SALLY: Tschuldigung, ich musste gerade gähnen.
Hat der Podcast eurer Ehe gutgetan? So als Ehetherapie …
MURAT: Definitiv.
SALLY: Definitiv ja.
MURAT: Und ich bin der Meinung, ganz ehrlich:
Selbst wenn ihr den Podcast nicht öffentlicht macht.
Macht einen Podcast mit eurem Partner.
Ohne Witz! [Sally stimmt zu]
SALLY: Wir haben vorher wirklich …
Also wir sind schon so ein Pärchen,
das vielleicht auch zu wenig geredet hat,
weil wir viel unterwegs waren und dann hier und da.
MURAT: Was heißt unterwegs? Du bist ja drüben und ich hier. [Sally stimmt zu]
SALLY: Jeder hatte einfach zu viel zu tun, so für sich.
Und dann bin ich abends zu kaputt
und dann habe ich keine Lust mehr zu reden.
Dann war der Podcast ein Termin [Murat stimmt zu]
und ich glaube, so wie Murat sagt,
man kann sich einfach diesen Termin setzen.
Ich meine, auch wenn ihr den Podcast jetzt nie veröffentlichen würdet:
Setzt euch einfach einen Termin einmal die Woche.
Ich weiß, als Mama und Papa von 2, 3 oder mehr Kindern
schafft man es oft nicht.
Da bleibt diese gemeinsame Zeit manchmal auf der Strecke,
weil man so viele Verpflichtungen hat.
Aber nehmt euch einmal die Woche zumindest eine Stunde,
und das schafft jeder.
Mit dem Partner zu reden.
Das schafft jeder.
MURAT: Du lernst den Partner auch neu kennen.
Vielleicht lässt du dich am Ende auch scheiden, weil du gemerkt hast,
dass es die falsche Person ist. Du weißt es nicht.
aber uns hat es wirklich …
SALLY: Willst du mir was damit sagen?
MURAT: Nein, will ich nicht, aber uns hat es gutgetan.
Wie du es gerade gesagt hast:
Abends hockt man sich hin und dann ist man so fertig.
Dann sagt man, ich brauche irgendeine ganz leichte Kost
und dann schaut man sich vielleicht Netflix an oder etwas anderes.
SALLY: Aber so ein Podcast ist besser.
MURAT: Aber so ein Podcast bedeutet, man redet miteinander und merkt dann einfach:
Oh, da ist ja eine Person.
Ich lerne meine Frau nach 13 Jahren neu kennen. [Sally stimmt zu]
Das ist ja auch was. Mach es auf jeden Fall.
SALLY: Wann kommt ihr mal nach Wien?
Ich muss sagen, wir waren die letzten Jahre öfter in Wien.
Klar, Corona bedingt ging es jetzt nicht mehr.
MURAT: Ich glaube, wir waren fast öfters in Wien als in Berlin.
SALLY: Ja, das stimmt. Und wir kommen auf jeden Fall wieder.
Ich meine, wenn jetzt erst einmal wieder
hoffentlich alles wieder Richtung normal wird,
dass wir dann auch wieder nach Wien kommen, zum Interspar kommen,
unsere Partner und Freunde besuchen,
denn wir sind super gerne in Österreich.
Österreich ist so schön.
Wahnsinn! Wirklich! [Sally stimmt zu]
Während du mit der Arbeit beschäftigt bist, wo bleiben deine Töchter?
Also oftmals ist so, dass sie bei Oma und Opa sind.
Ich bin auch sehr froh, dass wir Oma und Opa haben und dass sie …
MURAT: Wir sperren sie in der Vorratskammer ein. [Lacht]
SALLY: Ich bin auch echt froh,
dass wir Oma und Opa haben und die beide gesund sind.
Die gehen mit denen im Garten, auf dem Spielplatz, sind bei uns im Garten.
Aber oft ist es auch so, dass sie einfach bei uns zu Hause sind.
Die Ela hat vorhin z.B. ihr Zimmer aufgeräumt.
Dann hat sie mit ihren Toniebox-Figuren gespielt, dann hat sie gemalt.
Samira kommt dann auch mal ins Büro rüber.
Also die sind teilweise hier oder teilweise mit Oma oder auch bei Freunden.
MURAT: Die Samira z.B. kann schon Videos schneiden.
Also sie schneidet schon Videos.
Sie lernt dann von Ariane, von den Leuten hier, von Dennis.
Oder die gehen hoch und machen Hausaufgaben.
Es ist sehr, sehr familiär.
SALLY: Oder Photoshop. [Murat stimmt zu]
MURAT: Wichtig ist, den Kindern ganz, ganz früh Photoshop beizubringen.
Ist ganz, ganz wichtig für Instagram, für die Filter.
SALLY: Was ist die wichtigste Gewohnheit, die ihr euren Kindern beibringen wollt?
Eine Gewohnheit? Dass sie immer ordentlich sind.
MURAT: Ist Ehrlichkeit eine Gewohnheit? Nein …
SALLY: Das habe ich auch gerade gedacht.
Nein, ist keine Gewohnheit.
MURAT: Einfach sauber zu arbeiten [Sally stimmt zu]
SALLY: und Dinge, die man begonnen hat, beenden. [Murat stimmt zu]
Da hatte ich auch neulich mit meiner Mama drüber,
denn Samira hatte eine Zeit lang keine Lust mehr auf Klavier,
muss man ganz ehrlich sagen.
Dann habe ich aber trotzdem gesagt:
Nein, du gehst bitte weiterhin
und habe dann auch versucht, sie wieder zu motivieren,
gerade bei Klavierspielen, muss man auch mal sagen.
Wir haben so ein Instrument als Mietkauf gemietet
und dann denke ich mir auch:
So ein Kind muss auch lernen,
das ist jetzt eine Verantwortung. [Murat stimmt zu]
Ich wollte das unbedingt
und sie hat uns wirklich monatelang damit genervt,
dass sie unbedingt Klavier spielen will.
Dann, finde ich, muss man auch am Ball bleiben.
Man muss auch als Kind lernen, dass es Dinge gibt,
die man tun muss, weil sie eben gemacht werden müssen.
Dazu gehört mal die Kehrwoche zu machen.
Dazu gehört das Zimmer aufräumen.
Dazu gehören Haushaltstätigkeiten
oder auch mal extrem früh aufstehen,
weil man eben als Erwachsener Verpflichtungen hat,
denen man nicht aus dem Weg gehen kann und man muss sie nun mal tun.
Ich finde, als Kind sollte man das lernen.
Klar, wenn ein Kind irgendwie weint und irgendwas tut
und es will es auf Gott echt einfach nicht machen,
dann sollte man niemanden dazu zwingen.
Aber jetzt haben wir sie eigentlich wieder so weit,
dass sie es wieder gerne macht. [Murat stimmt zu]
Was würdet ihr eurem früheren Ich mit auf den Weg geben?
Ich würde meinem früheren Ich
ein bisschen mehr Selbstbewusstsein auf den Weg geben.
MURAT: Stimmt, du warst damals nicht selbstbewusst.
Deswegen habe ich dich auch gekriegt.
SALLY: Ich war sehr schüchtern.
Ich war sehr selbstkritisch, habe nicht an mich geglaubt.
MURAT: Dann ist es oft so, wenn Menschen so sind,
dann treten sie meistens in eine Sekte ein
SALLY: und du hast dann einfach geheiratet, richtig?
Ja.
Ich würde meinem früheren Ich echt mehr Selbstbewusstsein geben.
Ja, aber ein gesundes Selbstbewusstsein.
Es gibt ja auch ein krankes Selbstbewusstsein.
Das sind dann die, die irgendwie im Fernsehen anfangen zu singen,
vor der Öffentlickeit, und vielleicht nicht sollten.
MURAT: Was ich meinem früheren Ich mitgeben würde …
Gar nichts. Ich bereue gar nichts.
Ich bereue wirklich nichts. Ist das schlimm?
SALLY: Finde ich auch gut. Ich finde es nicht schlimm.
Man hat ja daraus gelernt.
MURAT: Wenn ich irgendwas weglassen würde, z.B.
hätte ich das und das besser gemacht,
dann wäre ich nicht die Person, die ich heute bin.
Und ich bereue gar nichts,
weil ich mit mir im Reinen und zufrieden bin. [Sally stimmt zu]
SALLY: Vielen Dank fürs Zuhören.
Wir haben jetzt hier die ersten paar Fragen schon beantwortet.
Wenn ihr die Fragen bis zum Schluss hören möchtet,
Dann hört euch gerne den Podcast an.
Den gibt es überall, wo es Podcasts gibt.
MURAT: Genau. Tschüss!
Im Kiosk …
SALLY: Schreibt gerne in die Kommentare,
welche Themen wir als Nächstes behandeln sollen
MURAT: Ihr bekommt übrigens den Podcast auch im Lidl an der Kasse.
Fragt einfach! [Sally lacht]
BEIDE: Tschüss!